hey guys dr berg here in this video we
want to talk about spinach okay uh do
you want the good news or the bad news
first the good news okay good good news
is it it's rich in iron
and magnesium i mean it's off the charts
it's also very high in vitamin a but
it's a pre-vitamin a has to be converted
vitamin k tons of vitamin k that's for
clotting and if you bruise easily you
want to consume that
it's loaded with chlorophyll
and also vitamin c
so it's really good for a lot of
different things in the body
folic acid b2 and b6 that's for the
heart
it's also
can be
it can improve macular degeneration it
supports the eye probably because the
vitamin
a and also because of all the
phytonutrients in there
xanthine and lutein and things like that
okay it's an anti-inflammatory and the
list goes on and on and on and on okay
so that's the good news
the bad news it's loaded with oxalates
and if you're predisposed to kidney
stones
you got to
just be cautious because oxalates are
certain things in the body that will
start to pull calcium and combine and
create stones
and that can be very painful
but there are certain things that you
can do to lower the risk for
oxalate stones number one you can steam
the
spinach but make sure you don't go
overboard and cook it too much
because you just kill everything in it
okay so if you steam it you decrease the
nutrition by about 11
if you fully cook it like i remember
going to an indian restaurant and they
serve this spinach it's literally been
cooking for a long time there's no
nutrition left in that thing
and there's probably no oxalates either
but steaming will lower the oxalate
lemon putting lemon on it will also help
the uh reduce the oxalates and potassium
citrate
okay so that's the supplement because
the citrates combine and actually
inactivate the oxalates
and then there's calcium calcium will
help reduce the oxalate stones because
it combines in your digestive system it
won't let it form in the kidney i like
to get my calcium from cheese and i love
cheese i'm from wisconsin and i just the
other day i had some raw milk cheese
from the swiss alps
unbelievable i love that cheese and it's
from trader joe's they have some really
good uh great cheeses um so consuming
calcium will also lower your calcium
your calcium oxalate stones all right
and the last thing i want to mention
about spinach is you really
make sure that it's always organic
because if you consume just commercial
spinach a lot of times it's from sources
that could been exposed to you know ddt
and other chemicals that are banned in
america but they come over from other
countries all right thanks for watching
i'll talk to you soon